we were extremely humbled by the support
of the local community
that happened almost immediately um and
it was
just it's been it's been um
it's been a relief to see the the
reception that we've received from the
community
the 25 reduction has capacity has
has really uh tightened the tighten the
reins and tightened the noose a little
bit so we're having to be
as thrifty and uh and um
it's just it has its challenges you know
getting open has the challenges
as we were opening during all of this
and uh in late october
and then to uh basically have it cut in
half again
uh it's been a challenge but the the
local support has been
keeping the doors open and lights on and
us being able to pay our bills
when it comes to that support do you
notice that people that are coming
in are so excited to have another
brewery in downtown
are they kind of craving that what's the
experience been like um
i think so um when i came back when i
moved here in 2013
um i did like a local brewery tour and
uh
there was a few breweries around here
that i thought
actually produced pretty good quality
beer at the same time i felt like uh
there could be a lot more
um so at which time is when i contacted
skip
and we actually uh you know if i got his
financial commitment that we could
actually put together a brewery
and so i felt like we could bring a
little bit of san diego to las vegas
so but i think the people are starving
for a place like this you know some
place that they can come
and release and you know put your phone
down have regular conversation
drink good beer you know and our place
here with
the way that we have it set up where we
can open up the doors it's just like
having an extended patio
you know for people where they get out
in the sun and the fresh air
and just to be able to enjoy themselves
when it comes to you know picking
this location in the arts district we
have breweries out in henderson there's
like a beer district out there why
here well i think um
first of all when we moved our first
company out here in 2013
i kind of had the vision of putting this
closer to the stadium
because we actually have warehouses over
there but at the same time
we met with the gal at the city and she
told us about the renovation project
down here in the art district
so i kind of spent a little bit of time
down here kind of looking around and
seeing
and evaluating and it just seemed like
the right thing to do
you know with the type of people that
come through the art district and
all the visitors that we hope at some
point in time are going to be coming
through here again
uh it just seemed like a no-brainer for
us to be able to
open a place and and then be able to
enjoy it
and it's it was nice that the city of
las vegas was behind not only this area
but our project
being able to a brewery brings foot
traffic we need people here it's not a
drive through it someplace you can come
and
hang out for a little bit and take and
take advantage of the shopping and some
other things that are here so
the city of las vegas um land use and
the the behind the scenes the nuts and
bolts of
why and how you can open up a brewery
the city of las vegas has done a really
nice job of
of opening some things up tweaking some
some
changes to where it's a viable the
business model has an opportunity to
succeed here
kind of talking about that hunger people
have for something like this
would you mind expanding on that a bit
because there are you know they're they
could go to
fremont and grab a drink down the street
they could go to container park you know
what
what's what's different about the arts
district i guess especially when it
comes to you know young locals what
draws them here
i i think that's right that's that's an
interesting question i think it's
everything about this area uh the
the craft breweries that are here now
which there's uh
one two seven of them there's a few tap
houses that are
really focused on craft beer there's
there's
wine wine tasting rooms there's um
there's just art the galleries the the
street art that's out
here there's so much of who vegas is
here and i think that's um we wanted to
we wanted to create this place to where
you this could be a stop along that path
do you think maybe one day vegas could
turn into a san diego
or a denver or portland when it comes to
the beer scene or
we we some years away from that uh i
think that we
it's kind of already started to go down
that path um
i know that where we come from in san
diego you know that it's it's like over
populated with a bunch of breweries so
that there's quite a bit of competition
here not so many but at the same time i
think that everybody that's in the craft
beer industry
we kind of want to be close together
because it provides people an
opportunity
not not only just to come down and drink
beer but everybody has a different vibe
you know and then i think that's what
makes our district also
you know interesting is not one location
is exactly the same
you know because other people think
alike uh you know
but also we are individualists and we
all have different things we like and we
want to share
and an opportunity for people just to
come out and see what they like or what
they don't like
so and that's kind of the beauty of
craft beers is
you know whether you like a beer or not
that's completely subjective
and the bottom line is if you like that
beer then it's a good beer
doesn't matter how it was rated doesn't
matter if somebody else doesn't like it
if you like it it's a great beer and
that's that's the art district that's
what art's about in my mind so
there's a there's a cool blend of
science and there's a ton of art in
making a beer
with their relationship with nevada
brewers i mean opening side by side do
you guys think you're
like a little beer hub right here where
people are stopping at to have this
experience but
what has that been like with them yes i
mean you can you can come to one
location
you can get some good food and some good
beer
and that's been and that's going to be
that's going to be this entire
area that is going to expand out there's
more and more restaurants that are
opening up down here now
uh me and you sushi and main main street
provisions and good pie all of these
have just opened up very recently
and um it's it's it's an exciting place
to be right now
we're just we want to be part of the
solution to the art district and for the
local community that's
that's why we were here we the local
community is is
is our customer it's who we need to have
sample our beer and if they love it come
back and bring a friend if you don't
try one of the others find find your
spot and enjoy life
i love that anything else that you guys
want to add anything i didn't ask about
that
is important to get across
no i think you know we kind of land on
our was about huddle it's a gathering
place
you know put your cell phone down use
your spoken words and over a great beer
make a new
friend it's it's been challenging
because we have to wear masks we're six
feet apart but
um we are going to get to the other end
of this the community is going to get to
the other side of this
las vegas is one of the most resilient
cities
and the way they support local
is um it's been very humbling and it's
incredible it's a better word
and we're just we're so happy to be a
part of it and
gain the trust of the local community
you guys open last september
correct we did we opened on september
1st okay so how has i been going the
past few months opening during the
pandemic and kind of dealing with
these you know continuing restrictions
there's been a lot of challenges we were
going to open in april that was our
original plan
we decided to scale that back when the
pandemic started
we ended up opening in september which i
think was a good timetable for us
we got off to a pretty good start people
were coming to check us out they were
excited that we were open finally
but we've been under a lot of
restrictions since then that's made it
very challenging
all the different so only so many people
can sit at a table
just uh having to take reservations just
there's been a lot of challenges tied to
all the restrictions
when it comes to you know especially the
locals that are here
has their have have they been receptive
to it have been they've been supportive
what has that been like i think the
local beer scene here is great i think
people are excited that there's more
breweries starting to pop up that we
have sort of a location that you can go
where they're clustering
the arts district has really started to
come alive i think it's added a
different pulse to the arts district i
think it's added a different culture
and i think it's just going to continue
to grow i feel like down here in
downtown las vegas it's kind of a hidden
gem
las vegas is almost like walking through
a time machine when it comes to the
brewing industry especially when it
comes to the western cities
we saw a lot of growth through oregon we
saw a lot of growth in california
even arizona some of the surrounding
states around us and for some reason
really the state of nevada was behind in
the brewing scene so i think right now
we're starting to play this rapid
ketchup
and uh these these breweries typically
want to go into places where you have
some culture and where you have people
wanting to come down a place that you
can call their own
main street is is always a pretty good
place to look for breweries no matter
what town you're in
so i think it made a lot of sense for
the breweries to kind of
start popping up down in this little
region right here
and eventually this will kind of connect
to the downtown area i believe
the strat is really only about a 10
minute walk from here so
you really are about halfway between the
downtown and the strip
and it's eventually just going to be one
big connection point and it'll be sort
of
i think the locals downtown area to hang
out it's really like this
hunger this craving for our locals
especially young
young locals to have kind of more
options
would you agree with that have you
experienced that at all yeah i think we
don't really have a really good spot for
young 20s and 30s to go i think you know
you sort of
have that a little bit when you get down
to the east fremont area
but really there really is no other spot
for
a lot of bars where they're together and
locals don't really like going to the
strip you do that when you have friends
in town when you have family coming to
town and they want to go and
do this trip maybe you go to a show
occasionally but for the most part
you don't want to go pay those prices
you don't want to deal with the parking
the traffic
down here you get a much more
family-friendly feel
it's a lot of family-owned businesses
it's a gaming alternative location
there's really not much gaming around
here
almost none of the bars down here have
gaming they're pretty much all
non-smoking
it's a very different feel it's a
different climate yeah
and what do you think the breweries add
to
this area because like you said you know
there's some really cool businesses
down here great restaurants what do
breweries add to that
breweries are just a little bit of a
different animal you know you get that
you get that different feel when you're
hanging out in the tap room
trying out different beers is it's sort
of a group experience
almost every brewery does flights where
you can try different samples or
you order that beer all over this one
can i try your beer
and you share beers i know we're in the
era of covid
so maybe we'll stick with just doing our
own flights where you just get
the four ounce samples of the different
beers right now but it's sort of uh
i guess it just adds a different element
of community and and making
new friends and it's just it's just fun
sure and
you know having the two you know crews
right next to each other and then soon
this
barbecue spot that's going in the middle
do you think this is going to be kind of
like a little hub
on this street this corner i'd love to
think so the city's promising they're
going to redo all the side streets down
here in the arts district soon
it's getting safer in the arts district
we've got new angled parking all along
imperial right here
our patio is probably one of the best in
las vegas
i think the two breweries sort of have a
synergy effect
and you know you couple that with
another restaurant going in between us
here i think uh
i think this patio is is going to get up
a lot of attention moving forward
what are you excited for over the next
few months what are you looking forward
to what do you think is gonna happen
for you guys honestly i'm just i'm
praying for limited restrictions i'd
like to see the convention center open
i hope that happens soon uh you know
maybe by summer time we're starting to
kind of get past the curve here
starting to get more tourists in town um
i
you know we're surviving we're making it
as a new business we're not eligible for
any of the ppp we haven't been eligible
for any of the grants
we're basically just caught in between
since we didn't open early enough so
we're kind of stuck in a position where
okay we're being limited by the 25 we're
having to turn customers away you know
during our prime periods
and we're not really available we can't
get any government assistance
so for us we need things to start
turning the corner
um otherwise you know we may not be here
um is there anything else that you want
to add about
anything i didn't ask about that you
think is important to get across
yeah we uh so we do have the big patio
area here we're keeping everybody
socially distanced we're having a ton of
fun down here
uh you know we we hope people will keep
coming out we're making it as safe as we
can for everyone we're limiting everyone
to four of a table right now so
come out please come down and have a
flight it's safe
you can sit outside the weather's
starting to turn we really haven't had a
very bad winter so
the weather has actually done us some
favors so that's been really nice
it's only going to keep getting nicer
don't be afraid to come down
we'll keep you socially distanced all
the tables are sanitized come out and
have a flight
get a pizza while you're down here too